have you gotten completely out from
under the weight of the Presley name do
you think
I think it'd be very naive to state that
I that that would ever happen you know
completely
[Music]
I wouldn't continue if it was just about
that honestly if I was showing up and
just doing that and that was the only
thing I was talk known for or anybody
talked to me about ever I would get up
and discouraged but thankfully that's
not the case the more important thing is
that there are people out there thank
God who just like real music that's not
necessarily A sellout you know soulless
music that's just kind of popular for
whatever reason at the moment you know
thank God there's still those people out
there that just genuinely like it
[Music]
when you've heard your voice in your
dad's voice it was just a I am I could
never sing like you can say I'm never
ever going to say that I'm more of a
singer or songwriter singer but
there's something that was really cool
and intimate and organic that's what I
thought yeah how'd you react
um I actually had broke down for a
second
I mean I was sort of overwhelmed
what was the inspiration for this album
and these songs because there's a lot of
soul here I think just going through the
process of uh re stripping
uh everything away and rediscovering
myself afterwards and
it was just a process uncovering and
coming out from from a lot of
things that were destroyed and having to
find what do you think he would say
about where you are today with your
career and the music that you're putting
out well I would hope that he would be
very proud of me of course
um
you know I would just hope that that he
would be I'm sure he would understand
what I'm up against as well and I think
he would be I feel music's important I
know that's there but I I need to
I feel music changes things and helps
people and
it's just really that's what it's about
for me he was one of a kind
he had it all
um he was a very special human being and
I think that's one of the reasons why
you know you see what you see out there
today individual people recognize that
there wasn't a any kind of mechanics or
machine involved in him or anything okay
I'm this way or no manipulation or no
agenda it was he was offstage who he was
on stage so that's a big that's a big
difference and people can feel that you
know people respond to that and it's in
his music and they respond to that as
well
[Music]